bonjour bienvenue à la semaine verte en
ces temps de confinement on se trouvent
tous dans une situation un peu
particulière et chez certains ça peut
générer de l'anxiété
beaucoup d'agriculteurs connaissent cet
état là aujourd'hui on vous présente une
émission qu'on jugeait nécessaires sur
laquelle on travaille depuis longtemps
une émission sur la détresse
psychologique en milieu agricole
pour comprendre cette réalité nous
sommes allés à la rencontre
d'agriculteurs et d'intervenants qui
leur viennent en aide
vous verrez donc des témoignages
touchants et des initiatives concrètes
pour lutter contre ce fléau
et ça les a fait fondre aurait pu monter
en gamme actifs
[Musique]
les nuits et un dérangé par des
cauchemars des cris venant ces faits le
lendemain matin il ya été rencontrés par
un psychiatre ou un enfant qui ont
évalué le risque du sida à l'occasion
avec mon épouse on sait trainières bon
français puis on pleurait on peut leur
être les deux qu'est ce qu'on fait
qu'est ce qu'on fait
peut pas quitter ton travail pour qu'ils
continuent à l'oeil
peut-être ruban pour gérer sa ferme du
jour au lendemain c'est m'y arrêter de
manger y arrêter de dormir en quinze
jours je les plus reconnus
[Musique]
daniel barry possède une ferme laitière
biologique à albanel ou lac-saint-jean
300 hectares en culture 125 tête dont
une soixantaine en lactation
il aime ses vaches ils les observent
s'assure qu'elle ne manque de rien
daniel barry les appelle affectueusement
ses filles un démo mais que j'apprécie
le plus long c'est quand je conduis mes
animaux au pâturage dont vous venez vous
un effet il ne vous en effet l'ipad 1 h
et de l'autre je me revois passera je me
sois parti à lille viennent me voir un
peu puis vont brouter sur l'eau ce que
ça vaut très très cher
le producteur ne pouvait rêver mieux il
avait une relève
l'avenir de la ferme et est assuré car
mon garçon et partir à l'école à la
pocatière 3 1 donc quand lui est parti
on avait un employé à temps plein il y
avait lui avais mon épouse et moi puis
un petit peu de temps partiel donc
kayode quitter pour les corses étaient
prévues très correct à un bond de
l'ouvreur était est en amour tout allait
bien mais un jour son univers a basculé
[Musique]
tu fait consciemment c'est moi et mon
épouse avec un nouvel employé qu'on aura
embauché montpellier super sympathique
très bon mais qu'ils n'avaient jamais
travaillé sur une ferme
pour compenser le manque d'expérience de
son employé daniel barry et sa conjointe
mettre les bouchées doubles les heures
de travail s'accumule l'épuisement
s'installent ils s'assurent du bien être
des animaux
pour le reste ils font ce qu'ils peuvent
on avait deux ouvrages par deux chez à
tête il ya des superficies qu'on n'a pas
pu tuer pendant quelques années parce
qu'on avait paul temps et on est même
s'il a eu du ter me serait payant
malheureusement
alors daniel baril poursuit il ne
parvient plus à entretenir ces bâtiments
ce sera le début d'une spirale
une descente aux enfers
j'ai eu pas je comprenais pas ce qui
m'est arrivé je reimer
oui fini par aller consulter
je me prends des titres je n'étais pas
très en forme et ça me permettait
d'avoir moins de creux d'être dès demain
tu n'es plus gage s'approche sur tintin
évidemment avec la médication fâché fait
face est fait correctement mais ça me
sourit ça me sourit malgré le fait que
je voulais passer ce qui me sauve et
quand même de de tomber plus cru le gant
par ailleurs nous apprenons que la
détresse des producteurs agricoles
continue de faire des ravages dans
toutes les régions du québec
[Musique]
quelqu'un qui prend aussi des
antidépresseurs sa ferme se trouve à un
kilomètre à peine de celle de daniel
baril il a vécu des moments éprouvants
lors de la construction de sa nouvelle
étable en 2016
même si les années ont passé et il
éprouve toujours autant de difficultés
on en parle et il n'est pas tendre
envers lui et pas un maniaque mes amis
[Musique]
c'est sa conjointe mélissa verrou qui
nous raconte son histoire
on avait une base ce qui est à peu près
au niveau de l'espace apprenant qu'un
moyen de 4 à 5 heures par trente deux
fois par jour
tant qu'on est déjà rendu presque à 10
heures de travail par jour on a un bon
dossier financier cette année l'ont fait
qu'on se regarde ses notes notre année
on se lance puis on s'envoie convaincre
dans le fond nos créances et d'embarquer
avec nous autres pour construire une
nouvelle étape
[Musique]
mais les budgets sont serrés très série
pour éviter des dépassements coup il
doit faire eux-mêmes une partie des
travaux
au printemps quand la température
commence à être plus clément mais mon
conjoint commence à faire l'excavation
c'est le printemps faut se dépêcher
avant que les plans commencent à
bourgeonner et tout ça viole islamique
sont à préparer tout le travail
mécanique afin pour la majorité des
machineries pour pouvoir faire les foins
24 heures dans une journée pour lui il
aurait travaillé pendant vingt-quatre
sarapo été suffisant toutes les fois
qu'on a va être une contrainte un
problème à gérer sur le chantier ça
ajoute un os qu il était rendu que vers
la fin de l'été ben quand les gens
arrivaient sur la ferme puis qui disent
inquiets comment savoir
il pouvait pleurer dans les bras parce
que tout cela ait pu y arriver tellement
j'étais trop stressée
là il y arrivait devant son assiette
aucune appétit le carré de 20 des
nausées
les nuits étaient dérangés par des
cauchemars décrivent n'accepter pierre
consulte on lui prescrit des médicaments
dans les jours qui ont suivi
ben c'est l'autre la situation s'est mis
comme à s'aggraver
il ya une nuit particulière où il s'est
réveillé en panique
amélie fait peur aux rats que je veux
mourir le producteur ira à séjourner
quelques temps chez ses beaux parents
sarr était impossible de les orienter en
tu restes dans maison si tu vas te
reposer pendant que tout dans le conte
chanté ses parents sont aux milices en
prendra le relais
[Musique]
on a cherché delahaye un séjour on a
visité trois médecins différents et
on est allé à l'urgence il ya eu des
pensées suicidaires on en a parlé et
s'est dit je vais avoir de l'aide mais
chaque fois qu'on allait voir un médecin
et on nous disait prenaient des vacances
monsieur vous êtes surmené mais comment
on fait ça prend des vacances qu'on est
producteur laitier en est seul sans la
ferme step up auxerre je lui ai vinci
n'a perdu son coup rejoint france est
scooté et s'est enlevé la vie en 2014
il avait à peine 40 ans il était la
dixième génération sur la ferme
familiale
on est en février 2014
il ya un bris sur le silo hermétique le
slow à maïs et françaises décident de
faire la réparation lui même y effectuer
la réparation mais il prend une décision
qui n'est pas nécessairement la bonne un
moment donné et qui ont un impact parce
que le maillot ce mois ci
et nous on ne sait pas à ce moment-là
qu'est ce qui s'passe alors on est rendu
au mois de mai et puis on s'aperçoit que
les vaches vont pas bien alors il ya des
avortements il ya baisse de production
problèmes de qualité de l'air
on se demande pourquoi alors alors
qu'auparavant on avait une bonne qualité
les et puis à force de chercher avec les
conseillers autour de nous mais un
moment donné on se rend compte que c'est
le problème vient de la réparation du
silo qui a été fait et pour lui vint ça
a été ça a été un coup dur qui pour lui
de prendre complètement confiance
et
il ya un matin souviens plus exactement
quand lancer dans les jours qui ont
précédé
on est en train de tirer les vaches
quand j'étais en train de faire la trêve
puis francis est à côté de moi les deux
bras ballants puis il était pas eu de
pot fonctionnel puis un moment donné il
le temps de brancher une vache morte on
est plutôt et logeant temps dépôt sur le
fumier et jésus ça vaut pour gueye et
que j'ai tout arrêté
je vais chercher finalement il était
pris dans le feu ni été rendue ici à
côté de la maison puis je lui ai demandé
c'est ce que est ce que tu eu des
pensées suicidaires
inoue le disais je viens d'essayer que
gégé titre où je peux tu es capable que
j'ai demandé comment
mais c'est à partir de leurs études
ensemble chez le médecin maintenant on
attend plus
[Musique]
en juillet françaises cotées me fait un
séjour
[Musique]
le double où on faisant cas ça a été une
décision vraiment difficile à prendre
j'aimais l'agriculture mais aussi même
si j'avais mon emploi à l'extérieur ça a
été une décision vraiment si cela
prendra-t-il voir les tables vides
devant les champs à l'abandon comme ça
ça fait mal au coeur
au cours des années geneviève racine a
développé de la résilience
elle se pose toujours des questions
auxquelles elle ne trouve aucune réponse
combien de producteurs agricoles mettent
ainsi fin à leurs jours au québec et au
canada
la seule étude disponible sur les
suicides remonte à l'an 2000
on y apprend que le taux de suicide des
producteurs agricoles est le double de
celui qu'on retrouve chez les hommes du
même âge dans la population en général
ginette lafleur s'intéresse à la
détresse des producteurs agricoles
depuis une quinzaine d'années sa
première étude remonte à 2006 trois
producteurs sur quatre se sentent
régulièrement stressé plus de 50% des
producteurs agricoles en haut niveau de
détresse psychologique élevée
on est souvent dans le double au niveau
des gens qui sont à un niveau élevé de
stress élevé de détresse par rapport à
la population générale selon une étude
de l'université de guelph en ontario
45% des agriculteurs canadiens
présentaient des niveaux de stress élevé
58% de l'anxiété et 35% des montres et
des indices de dépression les facteurs
de stress sont multiples en vêtements
diminution des revenus augmentation des
dépenses entente et compétitions
internationales mettez au changement
climatique hausse des exigences
environnementales pression des groupes
d'activistes manque de main-d'oeuvre
isolement toutes les régions sont
touchées toutes les productions sont
concernés et cela touche tous les
groupes d'âge les femmes plus que les
hommes
en plus d'avoir à performer sur sa ferme
à délaisse pas pour autant tu es toute
la sphère familiale avec ça ça peut
faire beaucoup
il ya plus de rôle les données sur le
mal de vivre des producteurs agricoles
sont inquiétantes
alors comment remédier à ce fléau
quand on a deux enfants et qu'on n'a pas
d'employés c'est pas évident de
concilier le travail et la famille on
travaille tellement que l'on vient et
volt et parce qu'on a pas de temps pour
soi
les solutions sont difficiles à trouver
tout
pour